[Music]
on this Wednesday night keeping kids
safe online the world's most powerful
Tech CEOs called out on Capitol Hill Mr
Zuckerberg what the hell were you
thinking Mark Zuckerberg's apology to
parents how to hold websites accountable
and where Canada is on regulating social
media Canada's national sport under
scrutiny there's something emic to
hockey and Canada the goal to eliminate
a toxic culture massive meth bust what
the police say is the Prairie's largest
drug seizure and sacred symbols of Hope
the two rare white buys and drawing
people from all over Canada took them 5
days to get out here to drive to an
Alberta First
Nation global national with Donna freen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with some tense moments
for chief Executives of online platforms
such as Facebook Instagram and Tik Tok
they faced a combative Hearing in
Washington accused of failing to protect
children from online abuse exploitation
and bullying uh Mr Zuckerberg you and
the companies before us I know you don't
mean it to be so but you have blood on
your hands you have a
product you have a
product that's killing people for 4
hours the Judiciary Committee put
pressure on some of the most powerful
figures in the tech industry as parents
and child safety Advocates looked on
they've been grilled before and it
hasn't amounted to much but this time a
proposed kids online safety act could
force them to introduce safeguards
Abigail Bean explains why it matters in
our top story tonight hopefully parents
hold up pictures of their children who
were exploited or died by Suicide due to
online harm let the record reflect five
big Tech CEOs drilled by Senators meta
Mark Zuckerberg took most of the heat
how many times was this wording screen
displayed I don't know but the the you
don't know why don't you know will you
set up a victim's compensation fund with
your money the money you made on these
families sitting behind you Republican
senator Josh Holly called on him to
apologize directly to those families I'm
sorry for everything that you have all
gone through terrible no one should have
to go through the things that your
families have have suffered he looked at
me he looked my daughter's
picture and nothing the mother of
11-year-old Selena Rodriguez who died by
suicide after online exploitation wasn't
buying it I don't think it's genuine
because he continues on with his just by
the way he was answering the questions
the CEO's reaffirmed their commitment to
keeping kids safe but backing bills is
another matter proposed American
legislation aims to hold tech companies
accountable if they suggest harmful
content to minors and would allow
victims to sue platforms and app stores
a study by the center for countering
digital hate shows a teen girl can be
exposed to self harm or eating disorder
content repeatedly and within minutes of
setting up a Tik Tok account as one
example it is a little bit like watching
the clown from Stephen King's It giving
evidence uh to the Senate today
explaining why it should be allowed to
babysit our kids and thankfully our
Senators are saying hold on a second
aren't you a monster that sucks the
souls out of children for Canadian
children in fact they may be at slightly
at more risk in comparison to children
in the United States this Canada
Research chair in neuroscience and
learning disorder says our country is
behind in regulating social media
British Columbia just took the lead by
limiting cell phone use in schools and
promising legislation to hold social
media companies accountable 12-year-old
Carson Cleland of Prince George BC
recently died by suicide after online
sex tortion we know that social media
can have specific effects on the
developing brain in terms of not only
their brain development but also in
terms of children's mental health
outcomes the federal liberals have long
promised an online harms Bill the
Justice Minister won't say when it will
be tabled but told Global News in a
statement it will include measures to
protect children Abigail Bean Global
News
Ottawa now to the allegations against
former members of Canada's world junior
hockey team five of them have been
charged with sexual assault over an
incident in 2018 and we learned one of
them Carter Hart goalie for the
Philadelphia Flyers surrendered to
police in London Ontario last Friday
there have long been calls to change
hockey culture and for zero tolerance
for violence bullying and hazing Eric
senson looks at whether these charges
could be a moment of
Reckoning in some ways it is painful to
look back at the 2018 World Junior
Hockey Championships remembered less now
for the celebrations than for five
players number 20 m McLoud number six
Cal foot Dylan Dubay and goalie Carter
Hart and Alex foron surrounded by
adoring fans then now all facing charges
a woman said she was sexually assaulted
by multiple players in a London hotel
during a hockey Canada event months
later it's taken more than five years
for charges to be laid the culture of
hockey has depended upon an indifference
toward the well-being uh and safety of
women and now finally we're seeing some
kind of a
Reckoning on any Canadian rink kids
learn hockey early and over time the
culture of the game hockey everyone can
play it's all around here but with
recent charges the resignation of top
officials at Hockey Canada and
parliamentary hearings some Canadians
are looking at hockey culture
differently you get them in that
environment probably bad things happen
what we've seen change is instead of
understanding the story as a few bad
actors What We Now understand they're to
be is a a wholesale problem with hockey
culture that there's something endemic
to hockey in Canada four of the five
players charged are in the NHL foron
plays in Europe but the league has said
little about it so
far over the next 3 days the NHL will
celebrate with festivities and the
allstar game in Toronto as far away as
possible from the charges of sexual
assault and questions of toxic hockey
culture the fact that this celebration
is going on here uh in Ontario alongside
this massive case it definitely puts a
cloud over everything that's going on
and it makes it hard to celebrate hockey
at all right now the attention of the
nation really needs to be on this story
because we need to be demanding better
top stars in hockey will be in the
Limelight in Toronto this week but down
the road in London where one player was
seen turning himself in five players and
the sport itself will face a more harsh
public Spotlight in the days ahead Eric
sor Global News Toronto breaking news
out of Saskatchewan the jury and the
coroner have just released
recommendations in the coroner's inquest
into the stabbing Rampage on James Smith
cretion and the nearby Village of Welden
Saskatchewan the inquest examined the
events of September 4th 2022 when mil
Sanderson killed 11 people and injured
17 others the coroner made 15
recommendations the jury made 14 they
include establishing a national alert
system more support for individuals Rel
Le from the correction system better
collaboration between RCMP and First
Nations communities and further funding
and training for security on the James
Smith creation a separate inquest will
be held in Saskatoon starting February
26th looking into the death of mil
Sanderson who died in custody there are
new recommendations tonight to improve
supports for veterans and their families
they've emerged from the tragic case of
Corporal Lionel Desmond who fatally shot
his wife daughter and mother before
taking his own life that was back in
2017 he' served in Afghanistan and when
he left the military he was struggling
to cope as heid petruk explains it's
hoped the inquiry into his death will
lead to
changes the families have been in and
out of courtrooms for seven years I
missed my mom internally and deeply um
my brother as well all of them on
January 3rd 2017 Corporal Lionel Desmond
legally bought a semi-automatic rifle a
few hours later he shot and killed his
wife Shaina their 10-year-old daughter
Aaliyah and his mother Brenda he then
fatally shot himself the tragic end to
the rifleman's battle against PTSD after
serving two tours in Afghanistan the
inquiry heard how Desmond and his health
care providers struggled to access his
military health records and how he faced
delays in trying to get care through
both Veterans Affairs Canada and
provincial Health Services leading to
what the judge called quot quote a large
crack in Psychotherapy through which
Corporal Desmond fell this has been an
arduous and emotional process judge Paul
scoville's recommendations include
making sure Ottawa provides a case
manager to Veterans as they transition
out of service and that the Nova Scotia
government improved the transfer of
health records by working with other
provinces and federal agencies along
with ensuring Frontline workers get
upto-date information on intimate
partner violence other recommendations
focus on better background checks and
reassessments for firearms licenses
nothing here relates to assisting the
bordon family for the tragedy that took
place but for Shaina Desmond's family
the report is a disappointment they
still live in the home where the
killings happened and say Veterans
Affairs has ignored their pleas for help
the first way to begin to help the
families heal is to help the family with
relocating the federal Minister only
saying overall changes have been made we
certainly want to to move forward and in
improving any services that we can in
order to make life better for our
veterans and also their family members
the inquiry recommends a special
committee to track progress on the
recommendations so they're not lost the
judge said to the passage of time after
the families have spent so long waiting
Heidi pic Global News Port hawksbury
Nova Scotia the federal government is
promising 362 million dollars to help
cities and provinces temporarily house
Asylum Seekers there has been a rise in
the number of people claiming Asylum and
that's resulted in extraordinary housing
pressures it is in reaction to the
historic flows that we continue to see
coming into Canada whether it's through
the land border or through um or through
airports so it's it's very much a very
expensive stop Gap measure but it's one
I think that's that's been essential in
the context to to keep shelters over
people's head the immigration Minister
says it is a short-term response and
longer term changes are needed as of
last week 7,300 100 Asylum claimants in
need of housing were staying in 4,000
hotel rooms in six Canadian
provinces RCMP are calling it the
largest narcotic seizure in the history
of the Canadian prairies over $50
million worth of methampetamine has been
seized at a southern Manitoba border
crossing Canada Border Services officers
at the boys ofan Crossing discovered
over 400 kg of drugs stuffed into
suitcases on a semi-trailer on January
14th investigators say that truck was
headed to Winnipeg and believe the
shipment has ties to organize
crime while the drugs were dist destined
for Winnipeg we also strongly believe
that they would have been distributed to
communities across Manitoba and possibly
two locations across western Canada and
into
Ontario the 29-year-old driver of the
truck was arrested investigators say
they're still working on figuring out
where the drug shipment originated
investigators looking into that deadly
plane crash in the Northwest Territories
have found the aircraft's voice recorder
and spoken to the Soul Survivor six
people died when the plane on route to a
diamond mine went down near the town of
Fort Smith last week investigators say
there are encouraging signs the voice
recorder captured good information
though freezing rain has hampered
efforts to recover the wreckage Alberta
Premier Danielle Smith has announced
what she calls a parental rights policy
in a social media post Smith says
parental consent will be mandatory for
all students 15 and under who want to
change their names or pronouns at school
we know that nearly all parents even
those who may disagree with the decision
of their children will love and care for
their children no matter what choices
they make Smith says she plans a number
of new policies involving transgender
adults and youth from restrictions on
therapy and surgery to participation in
sport gender reassignment surgery will
be banned for those 17 and under the
Alberta Premier says child protection
laws will be enforced in situations
where parents become abusive or reject a
child who identifies as transgender as
well parents must opt in for their
children to be taught gender sexual
orientation and sexuality in schools
Alberta is opening talks with water
license holders in three Southern river
basins in an attempt to manage a
worsening drought major water users
would agree to take less water in in
order to help others Downstream in the
event of a severe drought this summer
each town has a water plan anyway for
shortages but you have heavy Industrial
in some places you have hospitals you
have senior lodges and commercials so we
want to know what they have and what
basic their daily use would be right now
there are 51 water shortage advisories
in effect across
Alberta Canada confidential coming up
the allegations this country's security
agencies hold too many secrets and the
Mystery that's washed up on the coast of
new land and
Labrador fears of a wider conflict in
the Middle East are still simmering
tonight the US has blamed a militia
group backed by Iran for that deadly
drone attack in Jordan that killed three
American
soldiers we believe that the uh uh the
attack in Jordan was uh was a planned
resource and facilitated by an umbrella
group called the Islamic resistance in
Iraq uh which contains multiple groups
including kab hezb President Joe Biden
has said he has decided what action to
take in retaliation it's not clear when
it will happen today Iran said it's not
looking for war but warned it is
prepared to respond if
attacked former top security officials
in Canada are alleging this country's
national security agencies are holding
too many Secrets those comments were
made made at the public inquiry into
foreign interference which has already
heard that as much as 80% of the
evidence it will receive will be
classified as top secret as David Aken
reports the woman heading the inquiry is
being asked to push back against what's
being called a lack of
transparency the country's security
agencies have been tracking instances of
foreign interference in Canada's
political Affairs for decades but most
of what they found remains classified
top secret hidden from the public the
culture the workload and the tradition
in agencies I think is to tend towards
overprotection but the very point of
this public inquiry into foreign
interference is to put some of those
secrets on the record an objective
endorsed Wednesday by a trio of former
National Security officials who used to
run Federal intelligence gathering
operations the inquiry can and should
challenge the government to justify what
can't be released and why the
conservatives have requested that the
commission forly name name interference
by Iran as a focus of the inquiry we
want the commission to follow the
evidence and make sure that we hear
specifically from those repressed
Iranian voices the commissioner's terms
of reference directed to quote examine
and assess interference by China Russia
and other foreign States or non-state
actors in other words the commission
already has the discretion to expand its
focus as it sees fit and it did that
last week when it formerly requested
information on alleged interference by
India that request now has the world
seek organization asking for intervenor
status at the inquiry and the sick
Community is primarily the community
that has been targeted by indan Indian
interference here in Canada so it's
absolutely essential that sick voices be
included finally a group representing
Wagers in Canada said it was pulling out
of the inquiry saying in a statement
they object to the standing three
Chinese Canadian parliamentarians have
been given at the inquire
parliamentarians the weager group
alleges are too close to the government
of communist China and which could put
the weager group in Jeopardy the
parliamentarians have denied those
allegations Donna David Aken in Ottawa
thank you Furious farmers in France
ahead how they're expanding their
[Music]
protests Farmers again blocked major
arteries into Paris today the ongoing
protests are fueled by anger over a lack
of protection from foreign competition
lots of red tape and high taxes the
French government sent armored vehicles
to protect a food market in Paris and 18
people were arrested during standoffs
with police the farmers protests have
now spread to Belgium and Italy and
their concerns are expected to be
discussed at a summit of EU leaders
tomorrow Italy has summoned hungary's
Ambassador in protest over the treatment
of an Italian
woman a 39-year-old primary school
teacher appeared in a Budapest Court her
hands and feet Shackled the images are
intensifying anger over her case she is
accused of taking part in violent
assaults against Neo-Nazi sympathizers
last February prosecutors are seeking an
11-year sentence it is a dilemma for
Italy's far-right government which has
formed friendly ties with
Hungary rare pair next what these white
buys and mean to an Alberta First
Nation a mysterious shipwreck has washed
up near a tiny Coastal Community of Cape
Ray on new finland's southwest coast it
was first spotted by a local on January
20th it has wooden dowels and copper
pegs they think it could be centuries
old it may have been dislodged from the
ocean floor during post-tropical storm
Fiona in 2022 a research team has been
sent to investigate and preserve it
there have been other shipwrecks in the
area and it's a reminder of the lies of
newlanders lost to the Sea a Ranch east
of Calgary is drawing lots of attention
because of some precious animals rare
white bison that indigenous people from
all over the country are coming to see
the ranches on the Sika First Nation and
white bison are considered sacred to
indigenous cultures across North America
how these bison got there is a moving
story with a serendipitous twist here's
Heather yuck
West his name is Tomahawk a rare white
bison living on the Sika First Nation
with his partner Kelly Spirit on
powerful and quiet the animals attract
hundreds of visitors every year the
furest that we got was from
uh I believe there a
nent was a family of five that traveled
down here
took him 5 days to get out here to
drive this fence tells the story each
ribbon represents an offering often made
by someone experiencing pain a lot of
people that come through our gate are
coming with hardships and I feel that
when they look into the eye of the
Buffalo that uh they're walking away
with a sign of hope that's because
across many North American indigenous
cultures these animals are sacred but we
enjoy it you know we get chartered buses
coming in lot of
Elders Tomahawk and Kelly Spirit haven't
always called Sika home four years ago
Carlin was asked to find a white bison
by a First Nation reeling after a series
of suicides he eventually found the
animals but the owner refused to sell
but then and he started telling me a
story about a gentleman in
Manitoba which is his father his late
father took in as as a son unbeknown to
any of them the owner was talking about
Lisa big snake's father when they
realized the connection he was moved to
sell I lost my
dad through cancer you know just before
the Buffalo came
and and I felt that it was a sign for
him to look after us and and put me on
that journey to U help people the way he
did in 2021 the big snakes bison had a
white baby boy Kuma kokam mikum now
lives on the standing Buffalo first
nation in Saskatchewan where he too was
revered as a sacred symbol of Hope
Heather urix West Global News seik Sia
First Nation
Alberta and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna Freez and
tonight's your Canada is this harp seal
near St John's New Finland in Labrador
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
global.com and thanks for watching hope
to see you here again again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye